[Applause]
right
the angela griffin brigade how are you
you're welcome
listen great thanks i'm a lady in charge
how are you
[Applause]
nice to see you thank you right ange
very competitive
so unbelievably competitive you don't
want to fail at this dude no we've
we've had a little pep talk before and
have you got what it takes stevie i
think we have after
we have come here to mess with winnick
meet tonight's family brigade the
griffins
[Music]
ex-chore actress angela is joined by
competitive husband jason
who's determined to outdo his wife in
the kitchen
angela's mother-in-law joan a fitness
instructor should have no problem
handling the fast pace of my kitchen
and burley brother steve a prison
officer will be on the receiving end of
orders for a change
if this family's fighting talk is
anything to go by they could be in with
a chance of being my top brigade
[Music]
right stuff right duck now the most
exciting thing about the duck is
slightly gamey very succulent but packed
with flavor
there's five spice in there don't over
season it with five spices
yeah touch your salt right heat the
olive oil you're certainly the duck not
boil the duck the big difference
now open it up so it doesn't all clog in
the center of the pan nice little toss
again don't leave it off the heat too
long the secret is getting a really nice
sear
on the meat spring onions in spring yes
oyster sauce don't go crazy don't flood
the pan with the sauce
just start off you can always add but
you can never take it away
yeah and again just tilt the pan and
just toss
if you've got the heat in the pan it
does itself you know that yeah the job
works itself there's not like a glazing
effect again that's exactly what you're
doing
good question what we'll do is lay in
the meat yeah yeah okay good cucumber on
that's been sliced the seeds have gone
the most important thing about taking
the seeds out of the cucumber okay it
stops
becoming really watery yeah all the
water and the cucumbers in this seeds
okay so we get rid of that i'm learning
right now
we've still got the heat in the pan you
can just hear the heat yeah nice
crispnet leaf
into the center and then from there
over and again right over the pan
that smells amazing and it's so quick so
it's exciting about this
okay it's vibrant it's very very healthy
and more importantly so straightforward
sure have a little taste of jesus right
now jay you like that beautiful book you
can meditate a spice in that
uniform now can we tell you something do
you get 50 portions
out like that 50 very demanding diners
we'll pay for that
okay are we ready yeah yeah yeah yeah
someone ordered yes four covers table
eight four duck
four sea green four milfoy yes yes yes
chef
excellent good one eight yeah okay nice
clean cool i like that
don't worry you'll get there come on
jason yes
you two got the same matching pajamas
right yes
do you feel at home now with a set of
chef whites on yeah how do you know that
hey trust me i've done my homework yeah
right here's the perfect way to get rid
of stress salmon fishing
let's go stevie wonder
weaving across the borders of england
and scotland is the river tweed
97 miles of stunning scenery and more
importantly home to some of the best
salmon fishing
in britain jack and i love fishing and
we're here to try and catch our very
first salmon in scotland
with the help of experts bill stanworth
and ian wood
gentlemen good morning good morning i
hope he's not jinxed today
could he say bill good to see you hi
nice to see you now
never fished on the tweet before what's
the chances yeah it wasn't a good chance
it's not an easy river to fish is it
sort of when you get down to the bottom
end of the tweet a bit wide down there
where we are today i mean this is one of
the prime middle beats so
yeah this is a good chance i've caught
lots of trout but i've never
ever caught a salmon thoughtfully yeah
are you ready this is an amazing river
you know that yeah there's a lot of big
fish out there but fish
seriously bigger than you okay so if you
hook into one
stand strong scottish salmon is world
renowned
it's organically farmed here to the
highest standards but caught wild
it's a true delicacy the tweed has one
of the highest salmon catches in
scotland
and jack and i are determined to hook
one of our own you know i can't look
like idiots today we're gonna have to
catch something
because these guys are hard asses
they're serious come on jump in
wading through the water will improve
our chances so looking a bit of a knob
is a small price to pay you look like a
womble
all the gear yeah and no idea
we're heading to some of bill's favorite
fishing spots to learn how to fly fish
the holy grail of fishing on the tweed
it's a completely different technique
isn't it from
trout throughout fishing yes yes christ
it's okay so you'll feel when it's right
there we are you're fishing sir
you need to walk the river casting every
couple of minutes
out of the 380 fishermen doing this
yesterday only eight salmon were caught
i was hoping jack would double our
chances
right jack go get your rod okay maybe
you have a lot more luck than i'm having
at the moment
don't catch one before i do why you're
in trouble
i'll send you back to school with the
two of us fishing and no quick catch i
was starting to appreciate while wild
salmon is such a delicacy
and i knew exactly what i'd be doing
with ours if we got any
when it's smoked salmon is at its most
flavoursome and it's most delicious
i plan to make some at home that will
taste 100 times better than anything you
can buy in the shops
but in the middle of the tweed that
looked like a distant dream
dad have you caught anything yet no not
yet mate
thank you jay no pressure they are
difficult fish to catch aren't they bill
that's all part of them part of the fun
of it at 41 years of age
scottish i cannot leave here until i've
got one
mid-afternoon we move to some faster
flowing water known as the cold
in desperation i changed tactics and
ditched the fly fishing for spinning
the way my dad taught me when i was
jack's age the technique of spinning
allows us to cover a lot more distance
across the water
then fly a lot quicker and you're
constantly reeling in
the lure imitates a small fish okay jack
yeah fine to maintain salmon stocks
conservation guidelines ask the put back
every other fish you catch
but that didn't look as though it would
be a problem today
my time is running out fishing for
salmon is all about patience
not my strong suit but i wasn't stopping
until jack and i got one
well we catch one we're gonna smoke it
and mate is there any time in your life
i'll allow you to smoke come on
where are they finally a bite on my line
[ __ ] yep he's on [ __ ] he's just running
down the wheel don't let it go
jesus oh [ __ ] he's strong
nice and easy look at the size of that
fin
as this was the first salmon i caught in
scotland if i could land it
i could keep it
[Music]
yeah beauty excellent
strongman there you go
he's done
[Music]
come on you're gonna kiss a few old
salmon trouts in your days come on kiss
one more
one more yes first ever
and i mate you're here as well yeah
together let's get buddy
well we're gonna smoke it now yep that's
gonna be really nice
let's go and stevie stop a little taste
you've got to taste
onion enjoy yourself jc i feel like i've
lost about four stones
right guys you're doing a great job
there's three tables to go yes
nice nice if you can't stop
[ __ ] me amazing here's the question if
you're both in the kitchen at the same
time who's the most dominant
probably jason i allow him i'll
get lost keep the pan away from the
plate
good girl well done nice and gently
yeah then we're all nice and clean last
minute sprinkles
up let's go well done i don't want
[Applause]
well that now let's hope they all pay
for it yes
well done
good evening ladies gentlemen welcome
nice to see you how was your starting
slightly peppery for me a little bit too
hot or um yeah quite a lot of pepper
it's overpowering
damn the idea of the cucumber going in
of course was to sort of cool it down a
little bit
combined with a lettuce of course to
make sure that wasn't too hot something
you could try at home
yes definitely yeah either it's
fantastic the duck was well cooked
not not overdone right it can get a bit
tough absolutely are you on a hard time
this week
should i be drinking yeah my mom my mum
knows she's
sometimes stuck is too rich for me
because it can be really lots of oil in
there but actually this
it's quite delicately flavored
jose okay
the number of customers that are paying
out of 50
that is fantastic 46.50
really good yes 46 out of 15.
yes really good now for me course i want
perfection
hey we're on the roll now we're on a
roll out of 50. well done great start
right on your section's clear down
coming up i'm with the fire brigade in
oldham trying to ignite a passion for
healthy eating
when was the last time the station saw
some lettuce in there oh yes
and david and elton finally come out
i should have trained that one for the
grand national
[Music]
[Applause]
joan any seasoning on that fish no [ __ ]
welcome back to the f-word time for the
main course
[Music]
saffron marinade fill it's a sea breeze
a nice sweet delicate flavor
and the skin once it's crisp is
delicious
score olive oil
saffron place the fillets skin side up
then just leave that to marinade in the
fridge
sweetens our peppers slice the thinner
they are the quicker they cook
hot pan olive oil
[Music]
season the secret now is to start
the caramelization sugar red wine
vinegar
that gives it this sour flavor out onto
a plate
cool green most exciting thing about the
sea green now is that it's changed color
hot pan skin side down
lovely season
once that's in the pan take your peppers
basil
and all you do is just mix that fresh
basil through those wonderful
sweet and sour peppers
[Applause]
[Music]
baste
[Music]
olive oil and that has to be the perfect
way of eating
sea bream with sweet and sour peppers
saffron marinaded bream with sweet and
sour peppers
done that's it good
toss i'm putting you in nice stevie we
can do this joe
yeah sure come on get all these out but
we're going to get good
absolutely let's just get them out fish
has got to come out the pan ladies yeah
james it's absolutely fine but if you
don't get it out
yeah let's go over cook let's go and
stay here
that fish is beautifully cooked by the
way absolutely perfect well done right
and you're happy with those
absolutely
[Music]
start again yeah stevie i want you to
finish this table with joan and then
we'll do a four together okay
you and i [ __ ] you now come on guys you
gotta step up again now yes
now this lot need help and it's a real
food emergency
firefighters need the right food to have
the strength to tackle their dangerous
job
you'd think they'd eat properly but when
they're on call they often take the easy
way out with fast food and takeaways
alison o'donnell is one of the four
percent of female firefighters in the uk
and the only one working at this station
we tend to eat a lot of study food
career
chips with everything it does make you
feel quite heavy
i don't like vegetables at all they
don't smell nice they're just
horrible it looks like i've got my work
cut out for me here
i'm in oldham to meet the white watch
firefighters who seriously need help
with what they eat
alison how are you hi gordon nice to
meet you likewise good to see you too my
darling that looks like hard work
it is hard work run me through a normal
dinner what would it be
a normal dinner would probably have say
curry chips
in terms of um budget wise i mean how
much have you got to spend on food
realistically it's about two pounds per
meal
per person so you don't get an allowance
no we pay our own food that's why we're
so stingy
anyway blessed are the talking let's get
you some pit on and get joined us
right you're right bossy car you aren't
you i'm going to show whitewatch how to
cook a healthy alternative to their
usual fast
food but first to give me an idea of
what they face day to day
they're sending me into a fire
simulation building to find a survivor
in the kitchen what would you cook a
chicken nut roast chicken
180 190. well typical house fire 1000
degrees
the simulation is designed to recreate
the conditions of a burning building
and disorientate me in constantly
increasing temperatures
i'm wearing a fog filter which impairs
my vision exactly like real smoke would
finding a casualty in these
circumstances is like finding a needle
in a haystack
the more i exert myself in the heat the
quicker my oxygen supply goes down
you've got 120. come on it's person's
departed come on
with virtually no visibility alison and
i eventually find the dummy victim
and i start carrying it to safety
[Music]
then my air supply runs out
and i have to scramble to get outside
[Music]
had this been a genuine fire i'd have
been in real trouble
that's manic in there oh my god i love
the heat but
from a kitchen point of view not from a
house on fire
having trained with allison and her team
i know that filling their bodies up with
stodgy food
is the last thing they need i'm going to
show them a healthy version of one of
their favorite foods
burgers and chips today it's alison's
turn to cook
so i'm taking it down to the supermarket
to get everything we need for just two
pounds ahead
are they vanier when was the last time
the station saw some lettuce in there oh
yes
right capers for the relish
excuse me you put me in a grass yeah
with a master i couldn't see
food oh it's all right actually
i don't think this will be under 20 quid
i'm hoping
that is going to come under that 1969
1969 yes look at that
[Music]
my healthy homemade beef burgers will
give the firefighters the energy and
nutrition they need
burgers don't have to be full of fat if
you make them yourself you're in control
of exactly what goes into them
the most amazing burger yeah yeah a
beetroot radish
and homemade chips right okay fried
mints
season with salt and pepper and then mix
smoked paprika gives depth to the flavor
cayenne pepper add some heat
tabasco sauce for even more kick i like
to remember not to scratch my eyes after
no no that's gonna be hot
add worcester sauce and ketchup to
season
mould the burger mix into patties and
place them in the fridge to firm them up
easy to cook later on guys how do you
like your burgers
rare medium big
loud cut potatoes into wedges and part
boil in salted water
baked potato wedges are a healthier and
tasty alternative to chips
then prepare the baking tray for the
wedges with salt pepper and olive oil
[Music]
[Applause]
season the parboiled wedges with olive
oil salt pepper a little tabasco sauce
chili flakes and finish in the oven on
preheated trays
right uh beet root and capers behind
yeah okay we're gonna make a really nice
relish now
beetroot is rich in iron add balsamic
vinegar
salt pepper olive oil capers and then
blend
flat leaf parsley adds an earthy fresh
quality to the relish
that's quite nice just said all that
beetroot that's lovely
we've done that quite quickly nice
chop salad to add color and toast your
bats to stop them going soggy
then we're ready to go
[Music]
hey are you hungry
[Music]
lovely tomatoes
a nice healthy quick yeah
under two pound yeah cheap burger
absolutely well done well done
very good come on guys let's just speed
up a little bit we can finish this one
properly let's go
let's go all right guys last two tables
yes i got one six and one table of two
yes
let's go let's go let's go oil in
oil done fish done
make that the best junk please okay
golden yeah come on guys
two tablespoons just concentrate on the
fish i'll do it
okay we've got eight here going
i've been there's lovely by the way how
many plates are now
four beautiful fish yeah nice color nice
and gentle
not too big jason the garnish never
exceeds yeah the main dish
and well the fish are still raw that's
the rule
quick quick quick quick quick go back in
the pan
peppers on well done yeah good check it
check check check clean the plates and
don't run away from me come on
double check that fish steve let's go go
well done yes jason seriously well done
yeah hardest ever okay clear down guys
yes
yes right time to find out what jana
street farm has been up to
over the last two months janet st porter
has gone all old macdonald raising veal
calves for the f-word restaurant in a
back garden in north yorkshire
[Music]
come on get on the case so far janet's
been keeping the boys indoors on the
advice of joe collinborn
a veal expert with over 20 years farming
experience
joe's helped make sure janet's calves
are happy and healthy with lives that
are a million times better than carth
kept in veal crates
he's advised keeping them indoors
because he reckons barn reared calves
are less muscular than free-range calves
so they produce more tender meat
however some farmers think slightly
differently
well this is such a dilemma whether to
let
david and elton out of their barn and be
free range
well i need to discuss this with someone
who's a bit of an expert so i've come up
to scotland
janet has come to dumfries and galloway
on the scottish borders to visit dominic
smith's farm
where he lets his cars run free because
he believes it produces better meat
hi hi so you don't think that keeping
the calves outside
makes the meat tougher because that's
what some people
say certainly not in our experience um
we found the meat very tender but it's
got a bit more character about
it almost all veal calves begin their
lives indoors
so in here we have our very young calves
that are still feeding milk
what's a pig doing in here excuse me
the calves don't seem to mind them and
they'll lick the milk off the floor
i can't believe it
[Music]
right where are they go on
at dominic's farm at 12 to 14 weeks the
calves are let out to pasture
and when you sell your mate you've got
happy customers who've never said
it's tough no well they do look very
healthy
so guys he's coming in with us he wants
lunch too
have you got a big car
free range farming clearly appeals to
janet but is it any good for the meat
the truth is in the tasting
never before has so much depended on one
steak
if janet likes the flavor and the
texture of dominic's free-range veal
david and elton could live out the
remaining weeks in the great outdoors
great
you have to be worried then for a minute
that's strong silence
i was thinking about it having seen them
tasted both sides of the story
janet heads back to yorkshire to decide
how to raise the calves for the
remaining few weeks
you say his meat's tender but um it'll
be a different type of meat than what
i'm producing but do you see
mine is on whole milk right away all
right i can see this i've gone 12
rounds right oh no i'm sorry john don't
apologize
i'm sorry you're a woman of principles
i'm sorry
very few men could move you weren't sure
i'm sure i'm sorry
i've seen how dominant does it and i
think for the
bit of life they've got left i want them
to have the same
view that i have so they start crapping
all over each other and wiping their
asses on the wall
i've made my decision they're coming out
jailbreak
oh yeah yeah go for it
[Music]
i should have trained that one for the
grand national
nevermind about golden's field dinner
definitely the right decision
[Music]
so janet and her cars are happy the only
beast locking horns on this farm
are joe and dominic there's a severe
physical stress there
so will janet's free-range gamble pay
off
we'll find out in a few weeks when david
and elton are slaughtered and served in
the f-word restaurant
let's just hope she's not having second
thoughts
[Applause]
[Music]
danny welcome back nice to see you my
darling thank you thank you always a
pleasure oh
now good news david and elton yes yes
come out
i just thought they've spit in that barn
now for quite a few months yes and it's
boring
they've only got a few weeks of life
left let them have a bit of fun
now that they're free range yeah it's
not that far away the end is in sight
are you getting attached or have you
yeah i'm involved with the
i'll be sad if they don't taste really
great
after all that effort see i think you're
getting soft did you know that because
already you always know
me is getting soft not one [ __ ] bit
i'll tell you gordon that my goal
is to produce me that you are not going
to moan about that you're going to be
proud of you're going to say janet you
did a good job yes
that's why i'm doing it you look great
by the way yes you've been definitely
rambling a lot you look free-range and
wonderful
ladies good evening
how was your main course very good very
good especially with the peppers as well
that was gorgeous
fine flavors when's the big day when's
the wedding you got your time you've got
your suit you're ready
i'm ready to come back
the flavors and everything just
literally just really subtle but they
all come through together
and it really really works and the
presentation is perfect
right jose results of the main course
meeting me nervous
thank you okay the number of customers
that are paying out of 50
for their main course is
46 out of 15.
really good
[Applause]
really well done now what do you want
for dessert
50 come on what do you want it's in
sight now yes
50 out of 50 for dessert yes when you
get a dish out and it looks fantastic
and you get a nice compliment then it's
it's it is worth it
that was hard i'm wet do i look like a
wet rag
because i feel like one that was pretty
stressful
i've never felt heat like that i
actually feel like i am in an oven
rather than a kitchen it's insane coming
up
rock legend meatloaf tears it up in the
recipe challenge it's a bag of frozen
peas
frozen corn that's disgusting
[Music]
[Applause]
right welcome back to effort now time
for the part of the show while i take
them assembly and beat them at their
favorite dish tonight's challenger
is mr loaf meatloaf
i just wondered if this is part of the
show are you ready to cook i i'm ready
to cook what's the dish cookie
i'm making meatloaf tuna fish casserole
surprise
the surprise the surprise what you don't
can't
i'm not telling you no i'm not telling
you what that thing is okay
and there's the dishes evolved over the
years or something that you've had
yourself yeah
it involved it evolved last night
actually yeah i've been watching you
i've been watching you
no what am i distracting you in any way
i'm doing something very very similar
i'm gonna do like a tuna pepper art
finished with some really nice
breadcrumbs
and then baked in the oven my secret
ingredient is this a chorizo sausage to
give it some heat
and more importantly give a really nice
color you're boiling celery that's right
disgusting you grew up in dallas i did
what was the food like
everything fried yup when i was a kid
there was a commercial poor fat marvin
can't wear levi's
and that was me my name was marvin and i
couldn't wear levi's
and did that make you miserable as a
child did that make you yeah hell yeah
you know what yeah you'd get there would
be parents
yeah that would say you're too fat to
play with my kids so how does that make
you feel
that's disgusting when was the turning
point in your career that you started
eating healthily i don't know january
no no since 89 89 yeah seriously
is it true you used to be a vegetarian i
was for 11 years
did you change your name from meatloaf
to nut loaf no that's a stupid thing to
say gordon
okay i'm going to start sweating off my
peppers shallots garlic with this little
baby here srijo
slice it nice and thin so the oil comes
out very very quickly
and we're going to fry it off okay here
we go sebagger frozen peas
hold on a minute boiled celery frozen
peas yeah and a secret ingredient that's
right
i'm wetting myself with excitement thank
[ __ ] a blind taster
i'm just going to quickly roast my vine
tomatoes just
straight into the pan now i have a bag
of
frozen corn really important to roast
these peppers chorizo
onions garlic give okay
while you're doing that i'm going to do
this right opening
my bag of noodles now three or four
tablespoons of sherry
into the peppers and tomatoes and leave
that to evaporate
you've had an amazing career you know
that pat over hell sell over 30 million
records
yeah but that's not near as good as you
know how many contest uh cooking
contests i've won with this recipe
how many you didn't check that research
out go on
so cocky
tuna in literally 30 seconds of the
pattern flash fried then out to drain
do you still party hard like an
old-fashioned rocker
are you getting a little bit deaf in
your old age
i said are you a little bit deaf yes
yes as a matter of fact now
what i've done so far as i boil celery
peas corn and carrots
and now i put them all in a big saucepan
with a little olive oil and i'm going to
stir them around for a few minutes
tomatoes have almost pureed down secret
ingredient
what is it meat come on nope not tell
until after it's over
what is that go away
what that's not customer no don't get
enough
what is that macaroni cheese what is
that
ah he doesn't even know after he's
tasted it that's wonderful
it's so secret even i can't tell what it
is it's so pasty
yes i don't care anymore if i win i
scored
chopped tomatoes gone in roasted
tomatoes gone in peppers and now we've
got this really nice rich sort of
pepperoni roasted garlic peppers
shallots
and tomatoes so flavour in there is
wonderful but the oil out the sausage is
giving this really nice dark rich
taste harika beans in when are you gonna
start that's fantastic
seriously oh man i hear that yeah that's
the best ever
that's the best ever that's the best
ever and i did it on tv
so right pasta on top as well cheese i'm
getting more excited
serious peppers at the bottom tuna on
top
well see if your judges are looking for
sophisticated taste
they're going to go with you if they're
looking for comfort food that they
really would want to eat
this is comfortable now i want to finish
this with some bread crumbs
parmesan and tomatoes i want the
tomatoes to sort of roast and get really
nice and crispy on top
the end is i take my crisp the end is
near i hope and i
and i break them up like this see right
on top
are you ready for the oven yeah yeah top
and bottom what would you like
uh which uh i'm gonna have the middle oh
[ __ ] me
okay quick quick okay there okay
okay good now they both go in there for
20 minutes we come back
and meat loses
[Laughter]
jack and i have caught our very first
salmon together yeah
now for the best part smoking it at home
[Music]
to help i'm inviting an expert to london
michael levesher makes award-winning
salmon which he smokes to perfection in
chimneys fitted with old wardrobes
is all you need when building your own
salmon smoker
as long as you can get smoke in and keep
it there you can hang your fish in just
about
anything i can't smoke the fish in the
house as i'd stink the place out
so michael's found me what he thinks is
the perfect solution
it's self-contained waterproof can live
in my back garden
and even has wheels
[Music]
what is that hello how are you
tilly how are you yeah good are you well
yes good to see you it's slightly shaken
but
also what a pile of [ __ ]
oh my god oh no i'm baffled to have
smoked salmon inside this we chose this
because it's got a good floor area and
there's enough space
from the roof to the floor to get the
salmon in to hang then we're just going
to board it in
put rails in we'll have the smoke and
we'll pipe it in we'll put a chimney in
it so we can
vent it out unbelievable in the back now
quickly let's go
in here let's go to the shops oh
jeez right we're off to clarity's for
lunch
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
having tried and tested our mobile
smoking machine it's back to the job in
hand
before a salmon can be smoked it needs
to be pin bone filleted and cured
which removes the moisture and helps
preserve the flesh
so we're going to cure it with some rock
salt sea salt sea salt and we're going
to add any flavors to that
you can add molasses you could say you
can sweeten it add some herbs
so at this stage you could put things
like um dill yeah do a hot smoked salmon
and we add thyme with that
crucial we leave the skin on and the
scale so that gives it a protection
ready yeah but because if we took the
skin off the fish will just
fall to pieces and salt on top like
loads of salt now
when you look at it it looks like it's
going to taste nothing but
salt and then within minutes it's
fascinating because it starts to get
watery right
it'll just it'll start drawing it out
yeah curing will help keep the fish's
color and give it a firmer texture
so we'll cure that now for how long
eight nine hours eight nine hours
then after that we wash it off wash it
off string it through the tail and hang
it up dry
good the salmon is left in salt
whilst we turn this piece of junk into
our very own smoker
right let's go let's build a smoker
we make a compartment from wood just
about big enough to hang the salmon
this will be a complete flat board on
the bottom add a couple of curtain rails
[Music]
and a couple of holes to let the smoke
in
and the smoke out keep the fire separate
to allow the salmon to smoke without
heat
and you've got yourself your own simple
smoker
[Music]
brilliant the smoke will be made
separately and cooled down before it
gets into the car
so as not to cook the fish so this is a
cold dry smoking yeah this is cold
smoking rather than hot smoking hot
smoking is smoking and then roasting
almost
smoldering oak sawdust will burn slowly
to create smoke that will give our
salmon this wonderful flavor
and that's the oat because it's quite
sweet isn't it yeah it's almost
caramelly
so it's very delicate slow process yeah
well it's just like
you can't hurry it's you won't get the
depth of flavor in the balance you'll
get a superficial
almost like a crust of smokiness we'll
replace and re-light the sawdust twice
in 24 hours just enough time to flavor
the fish
and how quick will that smoke go in
there it's coming through already
it's smoking yeah now it's ready for the
fish jack ready to put the salmon in
there
yeah let's go with the smoker finished
and the oak sawdust lit
it's in with the salmon that jack and i
caught in scotland
the salmon jack scott is the one we
caught and the one the girls have got
was also caught
that morning yeah filleted cured and now
for the final process smoking it smells
quite sweet doesn't it yeah
okay just spread them out so they'd
evenly that's brilliant
24 hours for us a mild flavor 24 hours
from our flavor
you want to be tasting salmon first and
then the sweetness and
the oak and the caramelly sort of flavor
the smoke comes along
the longer you smoke a fish like this
the deeper the flavor
we're leaving ours overnight
[Music]
the next day the ramsay boys smoked
salmon is ready for the family verdict
right ready for some smoked salmon
yeah yes all night last night
and then this morning wow look at the
color of that who'd like a little taste
first
that is delicious that is amazing
should we have some sandwiches yeah sour
cream
capers grate some lemon in there
some chervil chop that up on there
the smoked salmon goes on top mate that
was a lot of hard work
yeah but the results are worth it tilly
there we go it's delicious caught
gutted cured smoked
and eaten hmm anyway we've all agreed
mummy said that we can keep the robin
reliant yes yes
[Music]
let's go guys work and talk at the same
time stevie we can definitely get 50 out
of 50 on this course yeah
no burnt ones on there nice yeah good
right steve they're well and truly
[ __ ] yeah yeah again
right time for dessert summer very
midfoiling with lemon curd very nice
some are very mild for it with lemon
curd and milk foie basically means
a thousand layers lemon curd sugar
eggs lemon zest
and then squeeze all that juice in there
butter onto a low heat with
and as it starts to come up to
temperature the egg yolks
thicken and now we're going to pass out
all the zest
[Music]
beautiful cool milfoy
bilo pastry egg whites and just brush
across the fila pastry second layer on
top
egg wash finally our third layer of
filler pastry
take your cutter and push hard
dust the plate with icing sugar at the
bottom
filler pastry on top of the plate and
then
dust on top hot pan clarified butter
it doesn't burn as easy as a normal
butter because all the fat in the water
has been taken out
into the butter
it literally takes seconds out
lemon curd as it's cooled down look it's
thickened
absolutely delicious lemon curd on the
bottom of the plate
to stop the fila pastry shaking around
lemon curd
on the disc first take your fruit
top it with lemon curd and then another
disc
another teaspoon of lemon curd
one more spoon
[Applause]
sit on top icing sugar and that has to
be the perfect way
of eating summer berries with lemon curd
summer berry milfoily done
steve yes i can't afford for you to burn
any more yeah yes sir
okay come on jake this one's about
systems yeah yeah yeah
you've been going yet what's gonna work
teamwork
six there i'm getting this golden brown
effects now that's it it takes a while
and then eventually
really good well done thank you chef
come on
you start with the ladies see we've got
to pick up the place now you're doing a
great job yeah come on
and they are beautiful by the way thank
you sure well done ange
thief [ __ ] oh
you're a [ __ ] expert at burning these
you know that huh
come on come on come on on the hot plate
are they ready yeah they're perfect
don't burn them stevie so we can plate
them up off we go let's go
here we have um there you go
yeah i don't know good [ __ ] cooking
perfectly now you okay
let's go
trust me next time you cook these this
at home for your friends you'll never
[ __ ] them up yeah but
even you steve take a photo and send it
to me yes
[ __ ] well done yet lay down guys
coming up the results of the recipe
challenge has meatloaf lost it
right welcome back to the f word now
time to find out if meatloaf is a sore
loser excited
ready oh there we go there's yours there
let me carry it over for you because
it's very very hard very much
is that out of the way trust me i won't
trip okay oh look at that oh
look at that okay i like this bit look
at that that's exactly what i was
looking for
look at that baby mine's perfect
just what i wanted right now seriously
before they got to get tasted okay
okay i'm gonna tell you what's the
secret ingredient please cream and
chicken soup
cream of chicken soup right where's the
look at that belgian fighter pilot let's
go um
this is not gonna be hard for them to
figure this one out
thank you first one it's very homely
yeah might be tomatoes i love the beans
in there
yeah the crust is a little bit dry
though to be honest and you actually get
a little bit too much of it
it doesn't really add to it at all it's
a little creamier sort of this yeah
cherry creamy it looks very cheesy it's
not as heavy as you would think but it's
definitely cheesy
i think the texture is quite thick
though difficult to get down
i prefer the one with the noodles the
flavors are just
lighter fresher it's just a tastier dish
i prefer the one without the noodles
i really like the use of the beans and
it gives a really homey comfort food
flavor
i like the one with the noodles i just
think the cheese and creamy sauce really
compliments the
tuna there i prefer the one without the
noodles
it has a lot more complex stronger
flavors in it
right here we go okay you know you think
you're gonna win
it was close what yeah which mean it was
close it was closed they're like
this was [ __ ] mine was good what was the
score three two
oh [ __ ] oh three two who won
yes but you know what they say two out
of three eight man
sucker
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes how was your dessert it was
absolutely a lovely garden can i just
say that yeah
please um really straightforward very
simple to do something you could try at
home
yes i had everything multivitamins the
antioxidants it was
absolutely fully loaded and every
mouthful i talked it's not me swearing
it was fantastic
how do you think you'll do ladies and
gentlemen i think she's been absolutely
fantastic
joni is the light of her life and she's
been so sensational in there i think all
the gang did great they did very well
very well indeed
were you pleased with them i was very
pleased and everything they sent i was
very happy with so
yeah job well done and a very talented
close-knit family
nice to see you both yesterday excellent
good to see you thank you very
puddi was much lemon and the fruit
worked
very well for me i really liked the
biscuit with it as well because
it just gave a little bit more texture
to it so yeah i really really enjoyed it
josie give me the results please thank
you question d
right the number of guests that are
happy to pay
for the dessert
36 out of 50.
not bad at all
[Applause]
yeah now take your talented family
brigade out of it and get yourself a
beer